- We are back.
Kal Penn is here with us,
y'all give it up!
(audience cheering)
His new book is called
"You Can't Be Serious"
and it's out now.
You've got to check it out.
So where does the title
of the book come from?
It's awesome.
- I wanted a title, that captures
basically a double entendre in,
you know, when I decided
I want to be an actor.
My guidance counselor said,
(Kelly laughs)
she said...
oh, I said, "I want to be an actor
and then I want to do
something in public service."
And she said, "You can't have
your cake and eat it too."
And I was like, really-
- [Kelly] Oh I hate those people.
- Like, as a 16 year old,
you're going to tell me that nope,
you're life possibilities-
- Your dream-
- [Kal] Come on!
- Yeah. (laughs)
There's a limit to your dreams.
- [Kal] Right.
So there was that and then when I,
you know, post, like done
a bunch of stoner movies
and played a doctor on TV and all of this.
- Love those.
(audience cheers)
- [Kal] Thank you, I love them too.
- Yes, Yes, Yes.
(audience cheers)
- But go off to work at The White House.
And it's a similar thing.
Oh, you're crazy.
Why would you do that?
You can't do that.
You're known for playing a stoner.
And, but the only people
who really focused on that
were journalists, you know?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- 'Cause they're trying to
get like the clickbait thing-
- [Kelly] 'Cause they just
want a clickbait story.
- Exactly.
- Yeah, it's unfortunate.
And I get that that's their gig.
But the title of the book-
- I don't. That's not real journalism.
- [Kal] Its not.
- Yeah.
And I said it.
There, it's out there.
Yeah.
(audience cheers)
- So the title of the book,
I wanted it to be a play
on both of those things
that you know-
- Yeah.
- That you can't be serious,
but you actually can.
There's a time to be serious
and there's a time to be
completely ridiculous.
- And what a horrible thing
for a guidance counselor,
whatever they say like-
- [Kal] Yeah.
Well she's dead now.
(laughs loudly)
- So wait, is it?
This is perhaps my
favorite thing in the book.
(laughs)
Is it true that you
almost took The President
to a strip club?
- All right.
(laughs loudly)
- It's a stretch to say almost took
but I did commit
and here's what happened.
It was my second week there,
third week there, right.
(laughs loudly)
I'm new to DC.
I needed a haircut
and I just went to the
closest place to my apartment
right outside of Dupont Circle in D.C.
And this guy Rudolfo, who's the barber
and he recognized me
and said, "I love your movies.
I heard that you're working
at The White House."
And just talks my ear off.
And I'm looking at my BlackBerry
trying to do work emails
while he's cutting my hair
and also trying to be nice.
And he says, "You know, I own a tapas bar
that you should check out."
And I said-
- I love tapas.
- Me too.
(audience laughing)
I was getting hungry,
so I said, "That's great."
And he said, "You should
actually bring your office,
The White House Office
of Public Engagement
to my tapas bar."
And I was like, "Oh, sure. I mean maybe."
And then I think you all
know where this is going.
- Oh my god.
- And then he says,
"Well, you should bring
The President too."
(audience laughing)
And people would say
those things all the time.
And then he said, "You know,
it's all on the house."
And I said, "You know,
there are a lot of ethics
rules at The Obama White House.
We can't accept free anything.
Why don't you give me your card?
And maybe I can bring
everybody for a holiday party
or something and we'll rent out your bar."
So he gives me his card.
I put them in my pocket.
- Tapas bar? (laughs)
- I get home.
I put my phone, wallet, keys on my desk.
I'm like, "Oh yeah, this dude's card."
And I look at it.
It says "Rudolfo's ladies topless bar".
(audience laughs)
- Which is amazing.
(audience clapping)
- And I was like-
- Which is amazing!
- So I had to go in the next day,
tell my boss what I did
because I could only imagine
that the Politico or TMZ story was
(Kelly gasps)
Kumar promises like
(laughs loudly)
strip club experience
for White House staff.
- Who is bringing the ones?
- Right, yeah.
(Kelly laughs)
It was fine.
And he was very gracious and
nothing ever came of that.
- [Kelly] Oh my god!
- Yeah, it definitely
put my foot in my mouth.
- No, yeah.
Second weekend too.
- Second weekend.
- Congratulations.
- Thank you.
- Way to leave some footprints.
- I do need to say that...
(audience cheers)
- I tried,
you were asking about the
title of the book before
and this is one of the things like
I tell that story for the first time.
- And people are like,
"You can't be serious."
- And people say, "You can't be serious."
And then I also walk through
things like voter suppression
and outreach to young voters
and what it's like to register
in the history of our country.
I just love that people
have been responding
to both of those things
in the same kind of chapter.
- I love that you have
all of that in one book.
What a great...
That's why it took four years
but I'm like just saying,
it seems like it has a lot of heart,
has a lot of humor, has a lot of facts.
- [Kal] Yeah.
- And yeah, it's really...
And you let walls down.
That's really cool.
And you didn't need to
though, just so you know,
like I was a fan
regardless of who you like.
- Thank you.
(audience cheering)
- Kal's book is called
"You Can't Be Serious"
and it's out now.
You've got to go check it out.